[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur TV 78 nous sommes le lundi 19
décembre voici les titres vous étiez
près de 6000 à être venus soutenir les
Bleus hier au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Régina revient
sur ce match et vos réactions après la
victoire de l'Argentine à
Mantes-la-Jolie les jeunes du dispositif
tchica mis en place par l'association
Jeunesse sans frontières ont foulé les
planches vendredi soir pour présenter
leurs pièces de théâtre au travers de
cette mise en scène le harcèlement
scolaire était dénoncé et j moins 6
avant Noël nous ferons un point sur les
marchés de Noël dans les Yvelines de
quoi préparer la fête
mais avant jetons un œil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
demain la pluie est prévue sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines du côté des
températures comptées 9 degrés pour le
nord et l'est du département un petit
degré de main de moins pour l'Ouest et
le Sud il fera 8 degrés à Houdan et
Rambouillet l'après-midi toujours de la
pluie il fera 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan 9
degrés à Rambouillet et demain nous
fêterons la santé au fil le point
maintenant sur l'actualité dans les
Yvelines avec Céline Charles
deux policiers des Yvelines ont été
retrouvés morts sur leur lieu de
villégiature dans la Vienne un brigadier
de police des Mureaux âgés d'une
trentaine d'années et sa compagne
élèvent gardienne de la paix
âgé d'une vingtaine d'années auraient
selon les premières constatations
succombées à une intoxication au
monoxyde de carbone lié à un problème de
chauffage un drame qui se situe une
vivomotion au commissariat des Mureaux
qui avaient déjà été frappé par le deuil
en 2016 un officier de police et sa
femme avait été assassinée à leur
domicile par un terroriste islamiste
lors de l'attentat de Magnanville
l'union fait la force pour gagner en
efficacité les polices municipales de
plaisir et des Clayes-sous-Bois vont
fusionner début 2023 les moyens humains
matériels et financiers vont être
mutualisés pour créer le syndicat
intercommunal de prévention et de police
de plaisir et les clés sous bois si
nouveau agents vont être recrutés pour
atteindre un effectif minimal de 30
agents le département des Yvelines
inaugure une deuxième maison médicale
départementale à Bréval la première
avait été inaugurée en octobre dernier à
Maule cette nouvelle maison de 590 m²
accueille 15 professionnels de santé
dont deux médecins généralistes
infirmiers diététicien orthophoniste
psychologue ou encore ostéopathe seront
notamment présents objectifs regroupés
l'ensemble des soins dans un lieu unique
et lutter contre la désertification
médicale le château de Thiverval-Grignon
a été réquisitionné en urgence par
l'État qui en est propriétaire pour
héberger des sans-abris d'une capacité
de 200 places le château est utilisé
comme centre d'accueil provisoire dans
le cadre du plan hivernal lancé par le
ministère du Logement il accueille pour
le moment 62 primo arrivant aux
personnes expulsées de leur logement
dont 37 enfants des personnes
accueillies devraient rester au moins
jusqu'au mois de mars prochain
et si vous aussi vous voyez une image ou
une information qui vous a marqué près
de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous le
partager sur Twitter et sur nos réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
on va maintenant parler d'une belle
initiative ce dimanche 18 décembre
l'association pharmacie citoyens et son
président fondateur Mustapha lahbaoui ou
emmené en sortie 19 enfants de l'équipe
de football de Guyancourt et 6 enfants
de Trappes au programme découverte de
Verdun et de ses musées les jeunes ont
quand même pu suivre la finale de la
Coupe du monde à la radio de retour de
ce voyage aujourd'hui ses enfants ont pu
visiter l'Assemblée nationale toujours
avec pharmacie citoyen et nous vous en
parlions dans les titres la France c'est
inclinée hier face à l'Argentine a
égalité trois partout à la fin du match
c'est au tir au but que les Argentins
portés par Lionel Messi se sont imposés
aussi entre joie et tristesse les
supporters yvelinois ont suivi ce match
d'exception qui n'a cessé de jouer avec
nos émotions le reportage de Régine
ralech
[Applaudissements]
tout avait pourtant bien commencé corne
de brume drapeau tricolore maillot de
l'équipe de France au Vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines les
supporters ont répondu présent
on va dire l'Argentine mais mon cœur est
français et voilà je suis française vive
la France mais l'Argentine a quand même
mené une très belle coupe du monde et
pour y avoir été il mérite à une de
gagner une petite coupe du monde près de
6000 supporters français remplissaient
les gradins et la fosse du vélo de Rome
national mais lors de la première
période ce sont les quelques supporters
argentins présents qui font la fête
l'Argentine mène 2 à 0
pour Messi pour du Maria parce que j'ai
soutenu la journée depuis 2006 et 2022
c'est pour pour Messi et pour la Gentine
en équipe de France elle est en dessous
on n'a pas on n'a pas tiré on n'a pas
cadré et la journée n'est plus agressive
[Applaudissements]
30 minutes de plus ou aucune des deux
équipes n'arrive à faire la différence 3
direction une insoutenable séance de tir
au but où les Argentins remportent
finalement la coupe franchement je suis
très très déçu moi je m'attendais à une
victoire sur c'est un match compliqué
mais on a su rattrapé mais que ça se
termine comme ça c'est
vraiment pas les mouches vraiment
dégoûté totalement dégoûté ce match
était un c'était que des un ascenseur
émotionnel
de la joie de la bonne humeur qu'on
passe de la tristesse comme ça d'un coup
franchement je suis j'ai rien à dire
ascenseur émotionnel pour certains une
revanche pour d'autres la finale de la
Coupe du monde aura fait vibrer les fans
de football et restera gravé dans les
mémoires
et pourquoi pas se donner rendez-vous
dans quatre ans au vélo de route
et pour vous remonter le moral
maintenant un maux de golf le
versaillais Antoine Rosemère a signé sa
troisième victoire sur le DP World Tour
le golfeur du Racing Club de France
âgé de 29 ans a remporté le mauricius
open sur l'île Maurice il termine avec
un score de -19 avec 5 coups d'avance
sur le deuxième Alfredo Garcia Heredia
en sortant de son tournoi Antoine Rosner
se dit très heureux et il espère revivre
ce genre de moment le plus rapidement
possible en rugby également de très bons
résultats pour nos yvelinois en Fédérale
de le Rugby Club de Versailles c'est
imposé au forceps 27 à 25 sur son
terrain contre Orsay et plaisir gagne à
domicile contre Saint-Malo sur le score
de 31 à 25 au classement les Marseillais
les Versailles sont sixième et les
plaisirsois sont leaders de la peau 8 et
nous les avions suivis il y a quelques
semaines lors des répétitions au centre
culturel le Chaplin de Mantes-la-Jolie
vendredi soir était le grand soir pour
les jeunes dispositif tia car de
l'association Jeunesse sans frontières
les collégiens ont présenté leur pièce
au public nous avons assisté à la
représentation
après deux mois de travail et de
répétition les jeunes de Mantes-la-Jolie
présentaient vendredi leur pièce de
théâtre
tu veux que je te dépose sur
devant leur famille leurs amis et les
CPE de leur collège ils ont mis en scène
une histoire autour du harcèlement
scolaire d'une jeune élève de 6e
une thématique lourde de sens pour ses
collégiens car 54% des cas de
harcèlement se déroulent au collège ce
projet était soutenu et réalisé en
collaboration avec les responsables des
établissements scolaires on fait déjà
nous un gros travail au quotidien au
sein du collège on a notamment au mois
de novembre une journée nationale de
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire on
a fait tout un travail de
sensibilisation une grosse journée de
sensibilisation autour de cette
thématique là une représentation qui
n'avait pas seulement pour but de
sensibiliser les enfants
à votre avis qu'est-ce qui est devenu un
SATA les parents présents dans le public
aussi étaient amenés à s'interroger et à
réagir sur la thématique j'ai tout de
suite été emballé puisque bah déjà par
le thème harcèlement c'est un thème qui
me parle parce que l'un de mes enfants a
été harcelé l'année dernière et du coup
c'est un fléau qui existe et je pense
qu'il va continuer d'exister et
justement il faut calmer tout ça il faut
arriver
à trouver des solutions à aider les
victimes et surtout en parler autour de
nous message reçu pour les comédiens qui
ont su parler à leur public comme en
témoigne le tonnerre d'applaudissements
qui a clôturé la pièce
[Applaudissements]
et noël approche à grands pas et à
grands pas il est encore temps de vous
rendre sur les marchés yvelinois la
deuxième édition du Marché de Noël de
Trappes est à découvrir jusqu'au 23
décembre une dizaine de chalets
proposant des produits artisanaux
solidaires des décorations ou encore des
confiseries seront proposés de son côté
a lieu la première édition du Marché de
Noël à l'île de loisirs de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines dans l'espace événementiel à
l'emplacement de l'ancienne piscine à
vague une vingtaine d'exposants vous
proposeront des produits locaux ou
encore des décorations de Noël
artisanales
avant de se quitter petit point sur la
météo de demain
[Musique]
on se quitte avec un mot sur la météo
demandez conditions très humides de la
pluie est prévue sur l'ensemble des
Yvelines côté température un peu de
redoute 9 degrés pour le nord et l'est
du département un petit degré de moins
pour l'Ouest et le Sud il fera 8 degrés
à Houdan et Rambouillet l'après-midi
toujours de la pluie il fera 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan 9
degrés 9 degrés à Rambouillet et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci pour
votre fidélité rendez-vous demain soir
pour une nouvelle émission en attendant
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]